a welcome back to coffee with kennel
today we are talking about three simple
YouTube tips that gained over a hundred
and ten thousand views so far on one
video and 1,900 new subscribers but if
you're new to the show this is the Q&A
show with me Sean kennel if we're just
meeting I'm the author of YouTube
secrets and founder of a YouTube channel
called think media as well as a few
other brands and my passion is helping
purpose-driven entrepreneurs build their
influence with YouTube in online video
and on this show at the beginning we
have like 10 to 15 minutes of focused
strategies about 3 tips for you and then
I bring you on the show to talk about
business online video live streaming
YouTube and how you can grow your
influence and your income faster so it's
good to see a cast what's up Jillian
what's up angel let me know what you're
drinking if you're watching this live or
on the replay I'm actually sipping on
some green juice inside of the thing cup
and I already had some coffee I'll make
a little bit more in a bit which eye
what's up just Samson Nathan let me know
we're watching from around the world my
wife and I just got back from a
seven-day trip in Salt Lake City Utah
took the UTV up into the park city
mountains took a lot of photos tested
some gear had a great time ate a lot of
food a lot a lot of food a lot a lot of
food but hey here's the deal man I hope
you're doing video right now and I know
if you're part of our community that's
definitely a focus of yours but you got
to be leaning into video live streaming
you got to be leaning into social media
right now and that's not just my opinion
I just read some recent stats and look
at this 3.8 billion people use social
media now in the world more than 4.5
billion people now use the Internet and
while social media users have passed the
3.8 billion mark nearly 60 percent of
the world's population is already online
so 6 out of 10 people have access to the
Internet
on planet earth but listen the latest
trends suggest that more than half of
the world's total population will use
social media by the middle of the year
and at the time of recording this
it's the middle of the year we're mid
June 2020 so half of the world like
total world population is using social
media can I get a like on the like
button tap it gently if if that's a
mind-blowing stat so I don't care who
you are you don't care no I mean I don't
care if you're a church a business you
want to start a side hustle you want to
start an Etsy shop you want to just make
some extra money online you want to
build a personal brand you want to be an
influencer dude you got a lean in right
now to social media you got to be
leaning in to online video and listen to
this from emarketer US adults right now
we'll spend 82 minutes per day on social
networks which is a significant upgrade
from our previous forecast of 76 minutes
and so this has been talking about how
because of coronavirus and the pandemic
a lot of consumption online is up and I
get it man it is been 2020 has been a
crazy year man has been just connect you
know what a what a year and it's barely
it's we got a lot more of 2020 I have no
idea what's coming up next man here in
the u.s. we got an election this year
dear God it's gonna be an interesting
year but social media and online video
and OTT and all of this kind of stuff is
very important and if you're a business
owner we've had people on the coffee
with channel show that have been
disrupted right and they were in travel
they they had restaurants and so you got
to figure out how to pivot online and so
that's what this show is all about now
before we get into some Q&A and I'm
gonna have Alena helping me today she'll
drop the link to join me on the show
remember you gotta have good audio you
got to have good video but I want to
share some YouTube tips with you and
break this down rule really quick so
look at this video a couple months old
came out in April so April May June it's
like you know less than three months old
okay 110,000 views this one video grew
the channel by one point
thousand subscribers think media okay
and I want to break down the secrets the
tips of this and what it is is you need
to study your top ten videos okay that's
the tips I'm gonna give you three tips
about that but first of all this is not
the first step you should make if you're
trying to grow on YouTube what is the
first step Shawn that I should do if I'm
trying to grow on YouTube you should
post your first 30 videos what ya like
before you even really worry about the
results okay you gotta just post videos
I'm looking for my notes here I lost him
somewhere there there and what we're
going to talk about is how you can look
into your YouTube analytics and find out
which videos are winning in which videos
you should make next and double down on
but if you haven't posted any videos you
can't double down on anything you
haven't tested anything yet so I want to
encourage you if you're just starting on
YouTube punch fear in the face punch
perfectionism in the face post some
videos post more videos don't worry
about the other people's opinions don't
overthink and even over judge yourself
just post a video type in the comments
when do you post in your next video or
your first video have you posted your
first video yet are you scared to post
your first video post the video grab
your phone Shawn but I don't have the
right camera yet will order it but even
why are you waiting grab your phone
throw it in the vertical mode get a
think media pop socket we don't have
these but we should sell them somewhere
but we need to get them online you know
get a pop socket and be like hey there's
my first video yeah I don't really know
what I'm gonna talk about you've seen my
first video before I'm probably not
gonna be energetic or entertaining but
I'm just pressing record okay so you got
to get you got to get some videos up
first once you've done that here's what
I need you to do I need you to study
your top 10 so here's how you get there
you're gonna go in your back-end YouTube
studio beta YouTube studio now not beta
it's the official studio you're gonna go
to analytics okay and that's so on the
side you got dashboard you got videos
playlists analytics you're gonna go to
analytics then what you're gonna do is
on the right side here you're gonna go
to
more this gives you a list of your top
30 videos ironically right you want to
study your top 10 but actually all 30
will give you great insights okay so
here is three tips for you on how to
come up with smart videos and how that
video that we put out on thick media got
a hundred and ten thousand views and
grew the channel by almost two thousand
subscribers by the way so far because
that video continues to get views and
it's because of these tips and the first
tip was I'm going to show you the exact
strategy and I'll give you three tips so
first of all here's here's the first tip
this was not the video this is a video
called Adobe Premiere Pro tutorial how
to start for beginners so I want you to
notice a couple things notice the
thumbnail which by the way is a stock
video is a stock photo from unsplash
which is free to use legal to use no
strings attached no money attached a
website where you can get cool
photography like amazing photography
it's called unsplash.com write that down
as a resource right okay so there's the
thumbnail you can see right there
next is it's got a little premier logo
it says how to start in fact we have a
video on think media I'll link that up
in the description that Omar shows how
to actually make this exact um nail on
your phone using Instagram stories very
quickly very like like in seconds
simple thumbnail but very powerful
thumbnail okay so this video one hundred
eighty two thousand views grew the
channel by two thousand one hundred
subscribers generated one thousand one
hundred and seventy three dollars so far
in Adsense which is cool and has a lot
of other monetization streams connected
to it like the Adobe software for
example which is a huge affiliate
program or a part of K so this video is
a winner and this video came out in
March
alright earlier in 2020 so what am I
telling you to do I'm telling you to
post video start Messi punch fear in the
face then I'm telling you to analyze
your top ten in your top thirty so that
video is crushing
comes out wow it's doing great so what
did we do
rinse and repeat so here's this video
you're gonna notice couple things dude
it's the same thumbnail bet you didn't
even did you know that have you did you
know what we do that sometimes did I
recycle this thumbnail miss but the
thumbnail on think marketing for this
coffee with canto episode I changed the
green to read from another thumbnail I
design change the money logo to a
YouTube logo change the contrast a
little bit cuz I had to get this coffee
with canto episode ready in about 20
minutes I just throw it together you
know what I mean yeah we get you got
stuff to do I got stuff to do okay so
same thumbnail but it's an iMovie logo
says editing hacks schemes same kind of
font and and same kinds concept but for
a different editor and lo and behold
110,000 views so far almost through the
channel by 2,000 subscribers why because
of studying the winners on your YouTube
channel and doubling down and rinsing
and repeating the process listen
success leaves clues now you have no
success to measure and listen there's a
failure is the stepping stone to success
not every video that we post does
amazing you post a lot of smart
strategic videos and if you want to know
our exact process for posting videos and
you haven't seen my free one-hour
masterclass that's where I really go
deep in it that's a think masterclass
com brought to you by think masterclass
calm today's coffee with channel link on
YouTube in the description and we'll
drop it in the Facebook comments alena
will drop that if you want to check it
out that's right I go down that's the
system in the process seven steps that
we go through on every video but then
you analyze the videos you've posted and
you double down on what's winning right
so here's three tips of how to do that
and how I look at the top 10 in the top
30 alright first question what is the
oldest video in your top 10 you should
remake that video so if I look at this
now and then
is the dream that we teach on that
master class all right think media gets
five thousand four hundred and ninety
seven views every 60 minutes obviously
that's always changing goes between
about four thousand and sixty five
hundred right now and about at quarter
million views every couple of days
somebody said the other day they're like
dude you don't even get views on your
YouTube channel you know what I mean you
get those like this those blessing
people in the comments I knew you liked
your channel's bed dog I was like yeah 4
point 1 million views a month dog cheers
anyways
could be a big we get about a quarter
million views every 60 minutes
our strategy is sometimes hard to see on
the surface and that's what we talk
about on coffee with candle in the think
marketing channel right is the behind
the scenes so a lot of these videos
right are getting views while you snooze
like my friends sunny says like like
views 24/7 365 you know and so I want to
study the top 10 and say what's the
oldest video so we have views in 2018
getting 219 views you know every 60
minutes views in 2019 2018 but in the
top 10 is actually a 2017 video that's
getting 123 views every 60 minutes which
is on how to name your YouTube channel
so I did cut on this on a style video
like this but not in like a well-made
video so naturally I go okay well that's
pretty old um
I should update that video so here's a
question for you what is your oldest
video in your top 10 if you want to drop
that in the live chat or comments or on
the replay let me know like which video
in your top 10 this is again assuming
you've already punched her in the face
started and you're taking action now
you're trying to say okay what topics
should I focus on that are winning so
question number one what's the oldest
video in your top ten and you can look
at your top 30 so I might go a little
further a lot of the other ones I phone
microphone this is interesting right
because deity just dropped a new mic so
I should probably revisit this like best
new iPhone microphones okay so really
I'm being told and actually had a live
stream with a DSLR which that's actually
quite a few new tools and
things have changed regarding that
that's on there too from 2017 so I just
got three if you will really smart video
ideas success leaves clues from my top
10 top 30 videos hit the like button if
you're getting value and we'll get into
some questions in just a second okay
second question what videos in the top
ten after a few weeks or months so the
next question is what videos are in my
top 10 better only that are there after
a few weeks or a few months so here's
what I mean the difference so we just
dropped this best portable SSD for video
editing video well it came out yesterday
so of course it's gonna be in the top 10
the reason it's in the top 10 is because
it's it's the most recent video so it's
getting the most recent views and again
I don't care if if your videos are
getting 5 use 10 views or 30 views and
you're just like you still should do
this like once you've got some momentum
once you're going you should you know
repeat the winners success leaves Clues
so so this video has not had a chance to
prove if it is a fit been effective or
not got it
but if we look and then some of them
which actually would be worth remaking
but they're also pretty recent like this
series with Heather and I on making a
youtube video start to finish with your
phone or this super video it's a forty
minute video step by step and then also
how to do with an M fifty like should we
remake those yeah but they're not
actually super old in fact at about
seven months old so they're very fresh
and they're doing well so but what I'm
asking is what is may be done well in
just the last few weeks or months that's
in the top 10 or the top 30
because for reaching your own viewers
and suggested views that following up
like following up your most recent
winners that are resonating make sense
so there's a good example like the Sony
zv1
the new kind of all around vlogging
although it's really not the best for
vlogging because it's so dang zoomed in
unless you want to have a giant selfie
stick on that guy but I digress
right for YouTube like probably the
ultimate like fit in your pocket travel
with you YouTube camera for sitting down
or get so we're gonna make more videos
about this and it's not only doing well
in just a few weeks oh and assigning
that grade of I mean it's really long 58
minutes but yet it's a it's truly a hot
topic so you're identifying okay what
semi recent videos could I follow up
with maybe a part two on this this video
on the background of Omar's really photo
studio background studio that's quite
affordable for like the level of pro
looks like a ten thousand dollar
portrait headshot studio that for a
couple hundred bucks you can build
anyways a lot of cool videos to check
out and think media but that's the next
question is what videos not in the
little in just like seven days but in
the last couple weeks or months have
done well that I should maybe make a
part two of that are kind of a recent
trend going on okay number three tip is
what topics or themes do you notice in
your top 10 overall or really your top
30 so again your top 30 is this entire
page inside of your analytics what
topics and themes for your channel stand
out to you so immediately how to make a
video with your phone so we might go
okay more smartphone videography videos
and accessories for smartphones how to
edit in your smartphone great clear okay
kind of same idea here how to make a
video start to finish copyright free
music okay what other copyright free
royalty-free music videos can we make
awesome okay how to start a YouTube
channel and get your first 1000 this
maybe shines a spotlight on focusing
more on beginning and focusing on first
1000 as opposed to maybe advanced tips
okay great how to name your YouTube
channel practical YouTube tips okay cool
smartphone accessories another trend so
what I'm looking to do is create a
couple buckets of of trendy of what I
should do video wise that people are
interested in for the next smart videos
I should make again this one just came
out today on five clever Road Wireless
go hacks so that one needs some time to
you really don't know how good how good
it's doing yet right how to get views
awesome how to kill folk oh I hope you
enjoyed that we did that of course I
don't think marketing fear of other
people's opinions message I'm super
passionate about right now but anyways
question for you what trends are you
noticing on your channel and drop those
in the comments like what topics or
trends or themes do you notice in your
top 10 or your top 30 success leaves
clues what you should do is make smart
decisions based on culture based on your
knowledge based on your passions post
videos you also shoot this post fit but
posts start messy and just post videos
without overthinking it because
sometimes like we just need to realize
we're not that smart like I'm not that
smart man you know like I've got good
strategy it's a good framework but then
what you need to do is you need to just
take action
I'm just glad I just I just put it out
there at some point you got a press for
court hit publish and let the video do
its thing and then though the smart move
is to say what can I learn from that so
I can begin again more intelligently
whether the video failed or whether the
video did good so what themes are you
noticing in your comments section so
slab gun said for me its precision
rifles with two specific calibers boom
make that part 2 and that could be you
might be going along getting what you
typically get for views all of a sudden
BAM you get another 10 20 X what you
normally get because you're making the
right videos that your community is
checking out so let me know
Travis is saying yeah posting low
hanging fruit video some basic camera
stuff awesome Travis super smart and so
yes Stephanie good see thanks for being
here Stephanie pumped Stephanie that is
coming as one of our speakers to growth
video live.com by the way if you haven't
gotten your tickets to grow with video
live the virtual experience happening
September 8th through the 10th 2020 go
to growth video live.com you can see all
the different details if you want to
master not just YouTube but
come on tick tock Instagram speaking
communication video podcasting we got
the Pat Flynn
we got the Chris Ducker if you want to
talk about personal branding we got the
the Michaela Alexis if you want to talk
about LinkedIn video we got the content
bug come on Katherine anyways check out
growth video live.com
so pumped Stephanie Liu in the comments
here is gonna be there and talking about
how to be how to go from unknown to
unforgettable on camera come on how do
you become irresistible on camera and so
many other great speakers and very
affordable you can go to that event
online for starting at just $97 so we'll
drop a link and all of the different
live chat comment areas and hit the like
button if you're getting value today on
coffee with Cannell Elina will drop the
link again i've got darby coming on in
just a second i hope you got value out
of those three simple tips double down
on your winners success leaves clues but
if you haven't started yet you got
nothing to optimize don't over optimize
at the start start messy start perfect
start poop your pants scared and just
punch fear in the face
my man darby how's it going where you
what what's happening in your life and
biz and what is it you do well i'm
actually brand new to youtube I've had a
YouTube channel for a long time what
I've been doing for the past five or six
years I've actually been a travelling
minister and I've gone and actually done
a lot of speaking around the East Coast
and started getting shifting into
coaching and probably within the past
six months I've been looking for a way
to bring my coaching and my art together
and actually created this channel to
bring both art and coaching together and
leadership development so that's what
that's what I do and I just joined your
what kind of art what's the channel
called it's it's actually it's funny cuz
I got my first hundred subscribers and
then I need to change the name but it's
actually Darby's 76 and this is a mic I
just did my first video just uploaded it
yesterday last night and actually Jays
it is this the channel [ __ ] yeah
that's it that's my first video right
there yeah
I know it hungry it's the first one yeah
it's a hero versus the hero or villain
that's my first video ever and I just
I've never done I've never done to
YouTube video before so new thinks like
you got like special effects and texts
coming in and stuff that's amazing how
did you actually make that intro I
actually used videohive I have done some
stuff before in facebook with Facebook
and have created some content here and
there but this is my first time actually
second speed drawing I've ever done
before and so the whole idea the whole
concept behind it is to to take a remix
of motivational kind of videos andrey
mixing it with speed drawing and
actually bring both of those together as
a hybrid that was a lot process man i
love it i love it that's awesome and
then you actually you have a couple
other videos on here or this happen
those are those are like testimonials
that's for my coaching the one you're
clicking on right there that's for my
coaching and those are testimonials so I
had a friend actually create this video
for me
he's been Peter Kindler yeah got it cool
well this is awesome and love what
you're doing how can i watch your
question today you know here's the
question I have for you so my thought
process is one is is that I you know I
heard about the low-hanging fruit and I
thought about this like I thought okay
to create this piece of content it took
me probably about 12 to 13 hours you
know overall and I know it's gonna take
time and honestly I'm looking at YouTube
as a body of work rather than just
YouTube you know and so so my thought
process is you know I was originally
gonna do it like twice a week but to be
R twice a month do these videos and I
actually have it in a series it's
actually coinciding with the hero's
journey which are twelve different
stages a hero goes through all the
stories that we love so goes through
each 12 the stages so I decided to do it
just once a month and then in between do
live drawing videos and anyway the
thought process is you know how
can they keep this thing simple enough
you know is it that I do more live you
know do more lives I have no problem
doing any kind of lives at all I've been
doing a lot of Facebook lies for two or
three years now
so that's not difficult for me at the
same time I'm also thinking well
low-hanging fruit is you know one part
speed art you know you're gonna be able
to reach a lot of people if I just made
it simply just the art and the music so
I'm just kind of working through those
things yeah it's a great question so
everybody watching and shout us out in
the comments if time is a challenge for
you I mean you got kids you got school
you got videos to create you've got
Final Fantasy 7 to play I mean you got a
lot of you know things that you have to
do on any given day Last of Us too and
so all these different you know things
of managing our time which is critical
when it comes to YouTube plus you've
also got potentially a skill gap because
one of the ways to condense time is to
speed up you know for example it used to
take me 8 hours 10 hours 12 hours to
edit a very simple YouTube video and now
I'm blazing fast but I've been editing
for 15 years you know so you get faster
but the biggest tip that I have for you
is to actually create content formats
and have them almost in different
buckets that allow you to make this
sustainable and practical so what I mean
is any given video I it was I was hugely
influenced by a quote from George Lucas
that said this no video is no movie is
ever finished it's only abandoned and
that's amazing because you think about a
Star Wars movie like it's perfect like
scenes are perfect that you know of
course you always find like maybe those
YouTube videos that discovered the 28
flaws of the background and that's what
he's talking about he's like oh shoot
the background was wrong there there was
someone there the audio is wrong what
does that mean it means that we could do
endless tweaking to any YouTube video so
a YouTube video could take an hour or I
could take 25 or it could take three
weeks yeah and that is a very huge
challenge for us
as creatives so learning to make YouTube
practical you have to think about
different types of content in buckets
one of the ways we think about that is
we think about hero videos and hygiene
videos and you already are kind of
touching on that you've got like these
big style videos once a month they take
you a little bit longer or quite a bit
longer
and then you're thinking about doing if
you will what's hygiene mean hero is
that video that hopes to rank in search
get a bunch of views go viral be a body
of work be something that you're known
for get discovered be watched over and
over again a lot of evergreen value a
hero video takes a lot of energy but
gets a lot of big results what's a
hygiene video hopefully hygiene is
something we do every day you know or we
at least do once a week like I try to
shower at least once a week
you're not I mean like that's you know
my you I try to brush my teeth
you know once or twice a day whatever
like so that's what hygiene E is like
consistent videos so to make those
practical you've got to put yourself in
constraints creativity does actually
work best in constraints so what can you
do and so here's what we do we we're
doing a series right now because lately
now we have a whole team of great
content creators that think media but
even they can turn one video into like
we had a conversation let's talk about
this video we're gonna review a camera
talk about the power of it for vlogging
we'll drive to Venice Beach before the
pandemic so it'll be like two hours of
traffic on the way there we'll shoot all
day there two hours of traffic on the
way back and I was like that's cool but
uh actually what if you just shot it
like in your backyard I know it's not as
cool as Venice Beach but like you could
save the time to make it more simple to
produce yeah and so one of the things
we're doing though is actually a QA
series leveraging comments out of think
media leveraging QA from the community
tab or from wherever we're going through
and then we're actually not only did we
pick out like 50 comments so I was
working with Nolan mole on the fake
media team picked out like 50 comments
then we said I said which ones would
actually like kind of be easy some of
them are like oh that would be a good
one we could turn that into a video you
haven't I'd have to research a little
bit like I don't know if I hobbie to
explain it take a lot longer
so then we actually like categorize them
into which could actually be semi quick
to answer but still really valuable and
then came up with ten of them for a ten
video batch shoot day yeah ask you all
ten yeah if you go questions and we have
a body of work as you know that's pretty
deep now so what's cool about these is
sometimes we can point to another video
pulling b-roll or some edits from a
video that's already done so even these
videos could kind of be spiced up but
make it practical for everybody watching
this you just then now have at least one
video to upload let's say a week that is
like one question one answer it could be
related to motivation for your case or
leadership it also could be related to
like like one tip like it doesn't have
to be a Q&A thing it could be like one
drawing tip like how to do a nose next
week like how to do a beard like
whatever it is yeah hower is think about
that ten videos recorded in one day is
really ten weeks of content which then
you can start working on your hero video
and maybe that takes me even multiple
weeks to produce and so summarize
everybody that's watching this we have
to be practical about putting different
content formats in different buckets
bucketz yeah I'd love to do all these
hero videos but maybe I can only do one
of those a quarter but what I can do is
then there's actually content mirror
pyramid it's hero hub and hygiene and I
kind of forget which each one is but
there's even the it basically the way we
think about it think media is that once
a quarter hero video the kind of like
once a week really well-made video and
then sort of like if you will the day to
day and that goes even into social media
like day to day micro or like pieces and
that also should be a trickle down from
all of those like if you go out and
shoot a hero video in our case that has
tons of b-roll and we actually do go
take out a camera our preference would
be to bring it multiple cameras to shoot
tons of photography to try to shoot like
four videos to shoot so much thing
b-roll that we could turn it into like a
four or five or ten video series and so
the energy exerted in going out and
creating a bunch of content
is then allows us to come home and just
edit that over multiple weeks and so in
each of us will have to apply this
individually to our content in our niche
but is that making sense in terms of
really making this sustainable yeah
absolutely it's funny cuz I just went
through I just actually I'm actually in
your your video ranking Academy and your
ads during the inner circle also and I
went through that video yesterday and
exactly what you're saying is what I've
been working through I wrote down here
on my man cave wall I have like 50
things that I need to like shift and I'm
like okay I just need to keep this
simple like I love these drawings I'm
looking at some of them take 20 hours or
take I'm like no way I am NOT going to
do that I'm going to you know ki look at
the videos I'm like well there are
cartoons that are just as popular and
there don't take as much time so what
you're saying to me is like spot-on it's
spot-on
Darby I'm pumped to hear that and glad
that that was valuable information it
makes it for also being a part of video
ranking Academy and inner circle how
long have you been in the Academy three
days oh nice the video raking Academy
foundations did you already open that
yeah so what I did was you you had you
suggested that you go to the one video
I'm on your grow your grow video
whatever I'm almost done that then I'm
gonna go to the VRA and I've all I want
you to know it's like awesome I've done
a lot of courses before and the way that
you guys have things laid out is very
it's very good it's it's very well laid
out it's I also recognized how much like
stuff you're giving away on your channel
is ridiculous
and sometimes I'm looking for this
certain thing and I find it on the
YouTube channel like wow it's like I
mean this is amazing so anyway so if
anyone ever thinks about doing it it's
so worth it it's so worth it well dude I
appreciate you so much and thanks so
much for your kind words about the
Academy and yeah crush those courses man
I'm pumped about your journey and all
the different talent and skill you're
bringing together it's cool to see that
sauron saruman versus Frodo drawings
whoo that's amazing and where were you
from again where you based Lancaster
Pennsylvania
Leyna the awesome Darby well hey appreci
thanks so much for coming on the show
today hey thanks a lot thanks for having
me
Cheers all right have a good day come on
you got to prioritize your time and
you've got to be practical about your
content Darby is in a situation man we
all find ourselves saying dude I got a
hundred video ideas to do right now we'd
even talk about live-streaming that's
another way to be consistent as well
which could be another if you will
upload on your channel maybe you do a
hygiene video every Tuesday but you
shoot ten quick short videos and you got
ten weeks of content maybe you're
working on a hero video and then maybe
you do a live show like this and this is
actually streams not just on Facebook
but also over on our think marketing
YouTube channel kind of simultaneously
using stream yard and if you ever want
to learn about our tools we have a page
called think media tools talk about the
software and mics and everything but
think media tools calm but anyways this
is against another upload it's another
piece of content be honest the lifespan
of this hour-long hour and 15 minute
stream not super good but the power of
being able to connect with the community
and talk with Darby and talk with you is
is really powerful it's just different
content formats we got the optimized
five-minute videos I've got longer more
optimized live streams where I like I
try to be really brief be bright be fun
be done I've got ones that are more free
flow like this and we can just kind of
hang out a little bit and sip on some
you know green juice and a coffee cup
coffee with Cannell 0:09
episode whatever it is so you want to
have like a list of different content
formats that you can pull from almost
like a tool box so you can stay
consistent and always get at least one
upload a week because that is the
foundation of crushing it well man we
got Michelle coming on super fired up
that Michelle here Michelle where are
you watching from what is it you do and
how has 2020 been affecting you so far
huh 20/20 has been a little rough so I
have my channels traveling she said I've
actually been on YouTube since late 2018
and really just started it as a vlogging
Travel Channel we traveled around the
world and I've been many many places so
I just started by doing that but I
really
thought about wanting to help other
people explore the world on their own
without having to go through travel
agents and guided tours and things like
that to really explore it on their own
and not be afraid to get out there and
explore the world so 20/20 has been very
challenging I have been laid off with
this pandemic and joined VRA during your
seven-day challenge and have really been
diving in and enjoying and trying to
make the best use out of it the thing
that I keep getting stuck on is I have
one video that has over three thousand
views and I cannot figure out why this
one video has gone crazy and all my
others are you know 500 views 400 views
and some of my newer stuff is less right
now but I just I'm trying to replicate
that and I can't figure out if it was
the topic the destination I was in or if
I did something special with it that
made it blow up god I got it okay I want
to make sure I find the channel sorry to
hear about you being laid off traveling
cheese head yes cuz I was born and
raised in Wisconsin
I can't live in Virginia Beach Virginia
so but yeah so I
orna raised in Wisconsin you know we
thought you know the sponsor nights are
known as cheeseheads
and it's so very much a part of who I am
so I know my title especially my channel
it's hard to pronounce but it is unique
nobody else is gonna have it and I've
seen other people that have weird names
and it's totally fine awesome awesome
okay yeah let's check it out so we've
got all of our different videos and
we're gonna go to our most popular and
then it is this Viva Wyndham Fortuna
Beach Resort tour okay right and we're
looking at why it's it's doing well and
I mean immediately it becomes pretty
clear to me and that is even when we
talk about video ranking Academy which
thanks so much for joining the Academy
we see a rank tag down here Viva Wyndham
Fortuna its ranks number two so when
people are actually searching for this
location there they're wanting to see
this
the Grand Bahama Island is also
something that they're interested in an
even fortuna Beach ranks number three
and so this is a super powerful
I think illustration and what this also
revealed to us is a content format that
you should double down on so it's this
is a great I'm so glad you came on the
show today because success leaves Clues
now interestingly enough when we think
about being a vlogger this is sometimes
the challenge with vlogging is when
you're a vlogger technically you're
trying to get people to buy into you
really your the value proposition
whereas if you actually have a value
proposition on your channel that is like
think media the the thick media channel
is not called Sean kennel it's called
think media and it's about the best tips
and tools for building your influence
with online video and Omar and Nolan and
Heather and Mel and Tony and everybody
shares there but there's the promise of
the channel yes of course like your
personality matters on YouTube
but what's the promise of the channel so
this video too has a very practical
promise and just to kind of give an
illustration of that to again a vlogger
at some point somebody has to either say
I want to watch you as a person which is
great but that's what you're essentially
trying to quote unquote sell you're
trying to get people to literally bind
you as a person the same strategy when
my wife and I vlog for a while and we
eventually pivoted away from that
because just I thought it would be hard
to sustain and grow personally so but I
did a video and I basically titled my
video search in a search based way
called Las Vegas horseback riding and so
seven years ago same kind of idea people
who just wanted to see if you will Las
Vegas horseback riding were finding this
video and here's this is in a way a
mistake it was good I started the video
with the promise of what was gonna
happen but again because it was a vlog
it was like hey we're at the house which
if you're a vlogger this is a good
strategy because
you'll meet new people that maybe just
want to go research a location a
restaurant a resort you know if you're
traveling it could be something locally
you want to deliver on the promise of
the video showing them the horseback
riding or whatever but then they may buy
into you and you're like look we're
actually vloggers I'm like if you want
to be like entertained and like see our
life or see our kit like whatever
because again that would be the value
proposition for vlogger if you want to
see some funny kids or a funny life or
more travel or mo load more locations
and to me again I just think that's more
challenging to practically succeed on
YouTube that way as opposed to seeing
what what you did now if we take the
full circle theme think about this is it
was actually a tour so people that are
like and we actually have world marked
by Windham is probably a little bit
different but like we might we would do
the same thing we'd be like well let's
go let's go look get a look at the
resort what is amazing
thanks for like walking me through it
like thanks for showing me oh and I'm
gonna make a decision if I want to go or
not but you could pull all these views
based on Bahama Island based on the
fortuna beach resort and so it's do you
have then a couple options here I would
think strategically would be you could
still continue to vlog as you are but if
I would would it be surprised if these
tour videos actually if you will do the
best over the long haul because I bet
this keeps getting views people will
keep watching it because it ranks and
search and it keeps showing up on the
other side of search results for those
terms and because you're already a
member of the video ranking Academy and
of course the update that we just did of
all VRA foundations that's gonna give
you a ton of insight for doubling down
and building like a snowball of momentum
on your YouTube channel but is that
making sense like kind of the initial
overview of why this video probably did
so well yeah makes sense completely
that's kind of what I was thinking when
I saw that those terms were ranking and
I was like okay so one thing I have done
with the Academy though is I've
diversified a little bit and
done a show as you have mentioned in the
Academy and I've done a travel tip
Tuesday and it's one it does exactly
your formula answers one question one
video and it's every Tuesday I have an
uploaded thing I just started it I'm
only like three episodes in and then I
also do supplemental things besides the
vlogging so I'll do like the best things
to see in Xyz location or how to travel
in this location on a budget I'll do
like more using my vlogging videos but
then repurposing them for specific
questions and is that a good strategy to
kind of build out my channel still
within the same nation yeah it's a great
strategy and I think the power there is
for where your channel is right now 87
subscribers you're doing I figured
exactly right what you want to do is
you're trying again different content
formats you're trying to show your try
and travel tips Tuesday they're all
being based on video ranking Academy 7
our framework and but then you want to
double down on what's winning right and
that's truly meaning we never want to
get overly romantic about a particular
format of content we test it for awhile
and maybe you know you think about it
it's almost like a product line for a
business you're like wow we started the
computers you think about like Apple at
one point and Steve Jobs came in and cut
a lot of products but it's like the
iPads doing decent the computers are
doing good the phone is doing great
maybe you put more energy into the thing
that's doing great you put more energy
into the content format that's doing
great on your channel but I think
exactly what you're doing right now you
should keep doing and doubling down on
and the other thing is of course based
on VRA and YouTube principles your one
ranked video away write it first at the
3,000 viewed video then you hit another
you know 7,000 V video and then momentum
builds over time but I do want to give
you one practical tip here I want you to
move travel tip tuesday to the end of
the title not to the front
so that way if this is an Singh the
exact question
people are asking how to sit together on
a plane and how to avoid random seating
asides when flying and then even if you
want to label it chapel trip Tuesday you
could do that I would show you exactly
how I did this on think marketing number
one today I ran out of characters so
this is actually coffee with candle so I
did three simple YouTube tips that
gained you know a promise even though
it's a Q&A show and then coffee with
candle would normally go here but you I
wouldn't want to put it before because I
want to lead with the value and the
answer to the question first and then
I'd move coffee to candle at the end so
here's an example is I would go how to
get over the fear of being judged by
others coffee with candles 0:07 and so
much so that I actually opted to not
even include this because I ran out of
characters and to me the show name is
way less important is much less
important than getting the viewer that's
like looking for information discovering
your video does that make sense
totally makes sense thanks that was a
great awesome Michelle whoa hey men
appreciate you so much and believe in
that this next part of 2020 will be the
best part of 2020 it sounds like it
wouldn't take much for that to probably
happen in a lot of our lives since it's
already here but really do appreciate
you and super pumps you're part of our
community we've got a lot of cool stuff
coming up in fact tonight we've got a
two-hour Q&A session with me and mal
coming up as well so I hope you can see
there as well absolutely got on my
calendar all right sweet Michelle thanks
for coming on thank you take care of
coffee with Cannell zero zero nine today
it's green juice with Cannell and let me
know what you're drinking if you're just
joining and let me know if you've gotten
value what's been your a ha moment so
far on this session because we've
already been getting into some great
tips it's awesome to see you here thanks
for being here sha things got some
British tea going on
we've got Christine her aha moment was
don't get overly romantic about one
content format
man that is a big one you know my wife
and I vlogged for 60 days or something
while I had a full time job and I was
doing it daily I admit that was a little
too intense if I did it just a couple
days a week probably would have been
better but nevertheless and this is not
to try to talk you out of logging but
what I evaluated was like I don't know
if this content format is going to lead
to my ambitions and my goals and then I
thought okay more search based practical
based value proposition promise based
content in a niche channel that could
also be connected to different
monetization streams could lead to my
exit plan and financial freedom I wanted
to turn my day job and eventually get
into my dream job so I needed to
navigate a path to do that and so you
can't get overly romantic about the path
if you had the goal you say well the
goal is the same
I want it to make me quit my job or hire
somebody new or pivot industries or
whatever your goal is in fact what is
your big goal in fact let's get real
practical here on coffee with Cannell
this is a huge one we got about six
months and 15 days we actually have 199
days left in 2020 I think so I think
that's exactly how many 198 somebody can
you somebody look that up I think that's
that's right based on when we were
recording this what is your ideal
outcome in the next three months okay
let's think about quarters you know kind
of coming up we're sort of in summer
right now here in the US the time of
recording this like what's your ideal
outcome and you might say my ideal
outcome is like I haven't even started a
YouTube channel and it's to quit my job
in the next three months that might not
be that realistic like sometimes it
takes a while to you chip away at your
side hustle why you got your main hustle
but maybe a better idea outcome would be
I want to earn my first 100 500 or a
thousand dollars in the next three
months and start building out my
influence or I want to get my first
1,000 subscribers or I want to get man
clarity is power and specificity
is power if you don't know where you're
going how are you gonna know when you
get there well it's kind of one of like
succeed on YouTube what does that even
mean where's kind of one like grow like
like how much money do you need a month
to quit your job ask somebody that the
other day in a coaching situation they
weren't even sure well then if you don't
know where you're going how you gonna
know when II get there like be specific
so I lean in right now what is your goal
in the next three months July August
September by back-to-school
okay which I don't know when your kids
go back to school you're like I don't
even have kids
Shawn Bradley's on the way Shawn Bradley
Cannell that's my first name legacy my
wife's dad's first name Bradley and our
last name Cannell from the Isle of Man
of Manx Scottish Irish descent so we got
people that want to earn their first
500-1000 online in the next three months
specific love it 300 subscribers clear
love it goal 100 subscribers beautiful
and so really great get clear but then
don't stop there then reverse engineer a
plan or a path to that goal okay then
start working on that planner the path
but be willing for the plan to change
see the goal doesn't have to change but
you might say like I hit this I have
grown I'm making a few may I made my
first 50 bucks online but based on
actually how this is working and me
doing the math what I've learned so far
I might need to pivot to actually hit my
target of 500 because I'm only making 50
and this niche I'm man or this industry
I mean you got to be willing to pivot
your plan but it doesn't mean you change
the goal doesn't mean you actually
change the destination now you might
also pivot your destination to a little
bit you know you might say I'm driving
from Las Vegas to Florida but I found
out Virginia Beach is super cool so
we're gonna kick it here
like you might change and like you're
still on a mission on a journey and you
have flexibility blessed
the flexible those who Bend and don't
break right but what's your plan what's
your goal let me know alright man we got
Nieman slimmer coming on my man how's it
going it okay what's up bro
good um what do you uh where are you
watching from I'm from Houston awesome
and what is it you do well I do gaming
videos followed by some game shows on
video games awesome man well they so
much for coming on the show I've seen
you in the back studio for a couple
weeks right you've been you've been a
faithful coffee with kennel watcher yeah
and now you're here yeah my man well hey
what kind of games do you play I play
minecraft roblox infeasible point night
okay awesome this your channel right yep
okay great great so what can I help you
with today what's your question
hmm well I think in some unlikes um and
I don't know what the problem with it
and I'm thinking out some problems how
can I figure it out yeah man well that's
a really really good question I don't
know if you've watched it but I want to
encourage you to watch this video on
think media that is on faux paux the
fear of other people's opinions okay
because you've been getting someone some
unlikes
some dislikes and this is one here's the
the thumbnail says you are stupid quote
unquote right because that's the kind of
stuff that sometimes people will say on
YouTube and so first of all I want to
encourage you for having the courage to
punch fear in the face to post videos to
be creative to put yourself out there
but I also you already know this but we
got to be aware that like not everyone's
kind in the world right there's bullies
in the world there's critics in the
world and one of the nature whether it's
you or everybody watching this is listen
sometimes we can be so hard on ourselves
like if I only did better if I was
better at content if
I made better videos I wouldn't upset
anybody you know I wouldn't offend
anybody I wouldn't give any dislikes but
that's it's not true the instant you put
your voice out into the world you're
gonna get pushback not everyone's gonna
like you and so I would encourage you by
seeing the dislikes you just have you
got to know that they're gonna come you
got to know that they're gonna happen
you know I love your shirt cuz it says
trust God and I was actually just
studying this and I had this question
right because I'm a Jesus follower and I
was like I was like you know what what
if I could be Jesus you know what if I
could be like perfect kind made no
mistakes never never messed up like
literally you know like we know Jesus
was sinless so we're talking about if I
was the son of God
like so I'm divine in nature and so you
want to talk about done is better than
perfect like perfect better than done
like Jesus walking in perfection he
starts a YouTube channel well is he
gonna have no dislikes what's crazy is
when you study it out dude homie was
massively disliked so polarizing like I
was just reading Luke and because people
were so mean critical like so you're
walking in perfection so I'm thinking
and and then I think about me and I
think about the think media team and I'm
like do we mess up all the time like I'm
saying the wrong stuff
I got have a bad attitude one day I roll
out I wake up on the wrong side of the
bed and so I'm gonna be flawed people
are criticizing how I look criticized of
what I say criticize and think meet
criticizing our information criticizing
my motive criticizing our intent and I
was like man so so what I realized was
it doesn't matter if you're perfect man
people are always going to find a way
some people to find something wrong with
the situation to be rude to be negative
to be critical and if perfection
incarnate walking the planet Earth 2,000
years ago was offending a lot of people
and upsetting a lot of people and
actually being disliked by a lot of
people and even to this day and even on
this very video
Jesus the most polarizing figure in
human history man split time and and
many you know our followers and
believers many are haters and many are
are not believers polarizing split split
I would say opinions what do people
think about so um bro I hope that
encourages you
because if perfection incarnate got a
lot of haters dislikes negative comments
criticism judgment judged of his motives
and then ultimately killed like I mean
ultimately literally being could have
never been a better human the god man
then we're gonna hit some some feedback
so I want to encourage you it's hard to
especially I would think at your age and
thanks for being on here it's cool that
you're part of you know did I remember
going through high school and I hated it
I hated sixth grade and seventh grade
especially I'm an only child and and it
was just a hard time man because you got
a lot of emotions and you got a lot of
you know just people will say stuff and
people can be really mean but that's
what I want to encourage you to watch
that video because what it is is it's
ultimately just come overcoming the fear
of other people's opinions good every
we're gonna have an opinion man like
it's everyone's gonna have an opinion
and and where we want to get it's a hard
place to get to bro I'm 36 and I'm still
trying to get to this place
I still feel other people's opinions it
still affects me negative comments
dislikes I'm like dude who is waiting
for my video to come out and the moment
I comes out someone clicks this like I'm
like did that person turn on
notifications just to click the dislike
button and I gotta remind myself that
you're in a pretty dark place if that's
that's the kind of life you're living
literally waiting for somebody else to
post just so you could be negative or
critical like I would hope you have
something better to do but in all
seriousness I want to have empathy
because anyone who's truly slinging hate
or criticism or or just being rude or
mean and this not to misconstrue that
people by the way I dislike just might
being somebody disagrees and I embrace
that you don't have to like the video
you might you might even like me but
like I don't like that video
like I like the channel but like that
video sucked cool like it's just not
getting wrapped up into it and John
Wooten said a quote that I'll look up
but let me know is this is this helping
you is this making sense yeah it is um
Don will set a quote that we all need to
hear he was a basketball coach and that
we all need to hear when it comes to
hitting YouTube content and putting
ourselves out there on the Internet and
man I really got to find this but it was
it was basically you don't want to get
wrapped up in the praise or the
criticism when it comes to he was
thinking like just you know being famous
and basketball or whatever they were
doing but here's the quote on a
massively pixelized image this is this
looks like minecraft bro
John Wooten you can't let praise or
criticism get to you like I think about
that it's not just criticism you also
don't really want to let praise get to
you because both is a trap
if praise gets to you you can it can
lead you into pride and if criticism
gets to you it can lead you into
discouragement self-loathing self-hatred
you know it can make you want to quit
it's a weakness to get caught up in
either one bro this is not easy
I have not mastered this but this is the
journey of posting content on YouTube so
I want to encourage you bro I love that
you're you're stepping out there I wish
I would have started at your age posting
content because bro I've been posting
for on YouTube now or I've been poked
I've been doing videos for over 17 years
and my first videos weren't that good
but I just kept going I kept posting new
ones and I kept getting better and I
kept loving without my skills but on the
journey dude some people are gonna love
your stuff go hit the like button
some people can hit the dislike button
and on either away it's like braless
want to keep creating I want to get the
feedback but I just want to keep
creating I'm not gonna get wrapped up
and left my self-esteem or my self-worth
ever be dictated by somebody else it was
like I think Eleanor Roosevelt who
um who knows what she said she said
something powerful uh she said something
about like come on somebody nobody can
make you feel inferior without your
consent
so bro I get that the lot the dislikes
can hurt but don't let don't let anyone
ever make you feel inferior you uh you
got to just have that confidence
independent of the shifting opinions of
other people yeah the helpful yeah right
cool man well uh what do you got coming
up the rest today you get you got you
can play some minecraft today or roblox
yeah then I have to go out for a jog
nice and where are you from again he's
thin Tech that's right well that's
awesome man way to stay fit as well keep
crushing the Minecraft keep crushing the
roblox keep crushing those jobs I just
went for a jog this morning well to
miler around the Las Vegas here so
anyways appreciate you in it's Nieman
and man and man that's your channel
right yeah my man cool bro I appreciate
you thanks for coming on make me take
care nobody can make you feel inferior
without your consent
dude the dislikes hurt man no matter who
you are it's sometimes easier said than
done but you just gotta keep moving
forward and going for your dreams and
don't let anybody who's giving up on
their dreams talk you out of yours or
try to bring you down it's always gonna
happen but dude if the god/man
perfection incarnate Jesus Christ got
haters and criticism and opinions and
negativity what hope do we have our hope
is not getting wrapped up into it and
scripture told us that he never
entrusted his heart to any man because
he knew what was in the hearts of men my
heart man my opinion shift I'm up one
day I'm down the other day I like it I
don't like it I'm at the restaurant I'm
like these in-and-out fries are great
then the next day I'm like only I'm
airing in dude everyone's got an opinion
man you gotta stay on your grind stay
focused keep crushing your dreams stay
focused on your goals keep posting
videos and you
gonna be messed up if you allow exterior
opinions and people and energy to
disrupt your conviction your vision and
what's your building should you get
feedback yes should you listen to the
comments yes should if you get mistakes
yes if you make mistakes should you
learn from them of course that's not
what your self-worth is wrapped up into
so booths leaked media a hundred percent
sticking that bad energy that's right no
negative energy allowed good vibes only
and and constructive criticism but it
should be constructive and when people
are just slang it just like cursing at
you calling you dumb dumb your stupid
dummy you know you're like do what like
and that's kinda what the Internet's
allowed somebody's hiding behind a
letter as their avatar with zero
subscribers and they're like you're
gonna let their negativity tear you down
come on you got videos to make come on
you got a business to build come on you
got to overcome the faux paux the fear
of other people's opinions and so
anyways hey I got a bunch of stuff to do
today thanks Ron and sha thing hopefully
we could jump on the next one and Glenn
goes dum-dum you know that they go
harder than that for sure man dude I had
a CMB see if you haven't seen it check
that out I was on CNBC I did a little
little special and in yellow it was nice
because a lot of you saw the video and
you showed up strong and you drop some
encouragement in the comments but this
was kind of cool to see I was on CNBC
what it's like to be a professional
Amazon reviewer and you know there was a
lot a lot of kindness down here but I
don't know we could even read reading
mean comments segments of coffee with
candle let's see if we can find anyone
I'll link this up check this out it's on
CNBC's youtube channel and so what WT
WTF this
lame-o there's Jeremy man thanks Jeremy
that's cool J bro one subscriber awesome
I am Filipinos this is to observe okay's
me you know it's mostly nice and that's
I think one thing we should really talk
about is what my friend Jon Acuff says
and it's called haters math so haters
math is that 1900 likes but we see the
140 dislikes a hundred and forty people
we're like I don't like this video I
don't like this guy
I don't like his hair I don't like it
you know say like better it's hurtful
man you grew up in a small town like me
that's like the whole town dislikes you
you know I'm saying it's like so haters
math my friend Jon Acuff says is 99
positive comments plus one negative
comment equals one negative comment
because it's the negative comment that
rattles around in our head like Jeremy
saying when the head this is lame-o
right you know what else we got here I
got some other good ones in here okay
great work well deserved so a lot of
kindness and I shared this out I
appreciate if anyone saw Matt you know
which but here's the deal man Christy no
is open to his own opinion he can think
this videos met that's great overrated
dude you seen thanks you seen there's
overrated dude okay cool I mean whatever
cool bro grown-ass man skateboarding cuz
there's a clip of me skateboarding dot
that dot that's not even hate you just
an observation
I suppose you know okay let's see
reading the negative but notice how I'm
passing by a lot of positive comments
now and I understand sometimes it flips
the other way and it can go really
negative and and you might get a whole
stream of dislikes and you you know you
have to respond potentially accordingly
and so lots of lots of positive comments
and this video also went out amongst
strangers obviously people who don't
know me and and they got to kind of see
some stuff you know whatever and so you
know junior
Walla eleven said wannabe and someone
like to comment wanna be just a wannabe
and I'm like cool bro
all I know though is I see you in the
comments but I never see you at the bank
who's the wannabe now can't cash your
comments Sean Bradley jr. is on the way
my wife's 26 preg 26 weeks pregnant went
to byebye baby or whatever that stores
called did our baby registry like this
stroller I'm not gonna be able to pay
for that stroller with your comments bro
and I'm not trying to be pompous I'm
just trying to say look man people are
gonna throw wanna be negative comments
that you just like such yeah you gotta
you gotta create anyways you got to post
anyways because you're dreaming your
mission is way more important than the
criticism that might come your way dude
everyone's got opinions good bad and
different and what I love I was just
reading it in the Book of Luke he's
talking about John the Baptist said what
you expect to see in the desert somebody
who is swayed by the shifting opinions
of men they're always shifting it were
hot one day cold the next day up and
down I don't want to entrust my energy
my confidence my mindset my my
discipline my focus my emotional health
my emotional way being well being to
something that's shifting and up and
down that's why you might want to
disconnect from social media a little
bit right now at times you might want
disconnect from the news alittle times
because this is not healthy to be
constantly shifting up and down up and
down even your super fans might be like
he's hot one day he's not one day I like
that new album that new song sucks like
it's just all over the place man John
woven had it right don't give too much
into the praise or the criticism stay
centered in who God made you to be
stay centered in your identity that is
not what you do but who you are your
character your values the person you're
becoming
you are not your YouTube channel you are
not your Instagram account thank God
because what if it gets deleted
right like what every whatever yeah I
don't wanted to get deleted what if you
get a couple copyright strikes they
delete your YouTube channel
they don't delete you as a person come
on you cannot have your identity wrapped
up in your business and your followers
and your likes easier to say than done
Sean I get it
I'm not trying to insinuate that I got
this figured out and that I don't find
my identity getting wrapped up into
external validation but I have to pray
process wake up every day and realign my
priorities my center my core my soul
with the things that matter most at the
end of my life I want the people closest
to me to love and respect me the most
what success really look like that's
what I think it looks like I got that
from John Maxwell the what Sonya think
about me and who does she think about me
my wife as a man did you think I was
kind I care about her said they're for
her
do we have those memories together at
the end of my life I want to be loved
and respected by the people closest to
me what are the think media team think
about me how did I treat and communicate
and talk with the people on the think
media team how did the people in the
video ranking academy doing in Q&A and
whatever how did they think about me and
that's a little far that's not probably
the closest to me cuz we got you know a
couple thousand people in there
well my parents think whether my family
thinking by the way your family might
actually think you're crazy and you're
not crazy but like they think you're
crazy can't please everybody but at the
end of my life and what the people
closest to me to love and respect me the
most not seems far too many people flip
their priorities and they just want to
be loved and respected and affirmed by
people on social media look man I love
you but you're probably not gonna be on
my funeral and the people who are I want
them to be like man he was a good dude
and he wasn't just one way when he was
on camera and on YouTube but this is how
he acted when he was in the backyard in
Las Vegas this how he acted when nobody
saw what he was doing
that's that inner game is that inner
life I think that's what matters most
because the opinions out here especially
in media and social media they're gonna
shift all over the place
and they're a gauge got pay attention to
him but you can't let him break that
barrier of that internal confidence of
who you are and what matters more was
God think of me what profited a man to
gain the world but lose his soul like
audience of one right at the end of my
life
did I live up to my god-given potential
and pursue the calling and purpose that
he place in my life just trying to
measure that's just success for me I
wonder what success is for you let me
know in the comments like how do you
define success and do you struggle like
I struggle with the fear of other
people's opinions we're gonna talk about
that a lot more and guess what
one of the reasons why we're talking
about it is because I'm preaching to
myself like for real like I'm hitting
this fear of other people's opinion
stuff I hope it's been encouraging you
because I need to hear it because we
went to we got a CNBC video made a whole
bunch of new people got posted on CNBC
look mom small town kid college dropout
now we're on CNBC crazy constantly new
people coming into our world with all
kinds of opinions and I was like man I
can't I don't want to bring this energy
when I clock out and walk down stairs
after work to spend time with my wife
Sonia and our baby Sean Bradley in her
belly I don't want to bring the energy
of all of the positive and negative
energy from the day into that
relationship by the way I do a lot and
I'm trying to grow through that and I'm
trying to be present with the people
that matter most in my life but my
closest friends do they really know me
do they know that I'd be there for them
I want to get better at that those are
the things that matter and so I haven't
got this thing figured out but I need to
clarify my values my vision and what I
define success as and then pursue that
daily and external success is cool
but not at the cost of losing our soul
or having external success and just
internal misery do the inner game is
everything right lot of rich wealthy
miserable people can't say there's no
reason not to get rich and wealthy just
not at the cost of what matters most
never losing your integrity never losing
your inner confidence never selling out
your most important values never
compromising your integrity your
character okay
I'm coming off the soapbox I hope to
hear from you what is your definition of
success question of the day coffee with
candles zero zero nine in the history
books whether you're watching this on
the replay Facebook whether you're
watching this I'm think marking on
YouTube what is your definition of
success and someone said I just see
Facebook user here on stream yard dogs
bark cats meow haters hey that's their
nature that's right man haters hate
that's just us what they are critics
criticize that's what they do potatoes
potatoes are your elevators haters are
my escalators come on okay like whatever
all right I appreciate you hey thanks
for being here let's get clear on that
definition of success and make sure that
you know this YouTube stuff matters this
livestream stuff matters but at the end
of the day you got to put on the Shelf
get up and grind the next day you want
to go home and lay your head on the
pillow and just know that you gave it
your best you put in the work you didn't
compromise your values you did a hard
day's work that you're proud of that you
felt you fought for your family you
fought for your community you fought for
your team you fought for your church you
fought for the people that matter most
in your life you fought for the causes
that matter to you you might not have
even won but you just kept fighting the
good fight so hey appreciate you
Kimberly I agree with you well done good
and faithful servant I want to hear that
too a pre
she ate you and thanks so much for being
here thanks for being a part of this
community means the world to me that we
can hang out and looking forward to
future coffee with candle episodes in
the meantime keep crushing it keep
smashing it keep grindin resources and
the show notes in the comments and on
the replay and I will see you in the
next coffee with Cannell peace